First person shooters are awesome, they're
action packed games backed by incredible graphics.
And if I wanted to quickly make an fps, there's
some really great options.
You've got easy tutorials in Unreal engine,
and Unity even comes with a fully featured
fps sample that works right out of the box.
But what if you wanted to build one using
something else?
Weirdly, anything Javascript related isn't
high, or even present, on the list of engines
that you might use.
I feel like I can make it work though.
I started by working on getting simple camera
movement working first.
First person camera systems are conceptually
pretty simple, you've just got the camera
wedged in the guys, or girls, chest.
And every movement happens relative to your
orientation.
It doesn't take much to get a simple scene
with simple camera movement going.
The devil's in the details though.
You can play around quite a while with little
details, like head bobbing is just a sin wave
that you apply to camera as you move, although
one little detail is that you ideally want
to stop at the end of a step, otherwise you
stop higher or lower like we've done here.
So a little bit of extra code to dig into
those kind of details really helps.
Once that's working, you may notice a problem.
The problem is that we can just pass through
walls, we have no collision detection whatsoever,
so we'll be integrating some sort of physics
engine.
I've been using ammo.js in my projects, which
is actually the bullet physics, a great little
open source physics engine that's good enough
for red dead redemption, so it should be more
than good enough for us too.
This should have been easy, but in reality
it wasn't.
The docs suck, the examples suck, everything
sucks, including me, I kinda suck at physics.
Anyway with enough trawling through forums
and stack overflow, I was able to cobble together
a working btKinematicCharacterController snippet
of code.
And the end result was that I can run around.
I can't pass through walls anymore, but I
can slide along them at angles though.
I can do all the things that you'd expect,
including jump.
Look I can jump, that came along as a nice
little bonus
Lets add some guns now
I grabbed this gun off of sketchfab, it looked
pretty cool so I'm happy.
There's not much to making it look first person
shootery, just gotta offset it right until
it's roughly where we want it relative to
the camera.
After that, shooting is up next, and the trick
here is to use ammo.js's raycasting abilities
to cast a ray out from our gun barrel and
see what it hits.
So whenever I press the mouse button, we fire
off a raycast query, and figure out if we
hit anything, and then react appropriately
depending on what you hit.
I'm not a violent guy though, so we'll make
this a paintball gun instead of a killing
people gun.
So to get that splat effect, we could use
textures, but i'm going to hijack three.js's
shaders to do this procedurally for more variation.
We also use three.js's decal system to procedurally
create decals from the underlying geometry.
Now when I fire off a shot, look at that,
we do a little splat on the wall and we get
our paintball effect.
The cool thing about this is that it rounds
corners nicely and you get a different pattern
each time you fire a shot.
Easing functions are an awesome little tool
to have in your toolbox as a programmer.
Because you can use them to procedurally add
animations to shaders or meshes like magic.
I added an exponential impulse to blend between
2 rotation quaternions.
And the end result is a little firing recoil
when you take a shot.
You can of course play with it, maybe recoil
more like a machine gun instead of a pistol,
up to you.
The next step is that I wanted to add some
UI.
I took Doom Eternal as my inspiration and
figured I could pretty much copy their layout.
The nice thing about using Javascript is that
I can do this all in html and css, if you
wanna call that a nice thing.
So I threw some style elements onto the screen
with 3d transforms and box shadows, and sourced
a bunch of icons from Google's free library.
So we have our health and charge bars down
here.
I gave this guy a chargeup power to run super
fast.
Ticks down the bar by just adjusting the width
and changing the colour.
On the right, here's some more ui, I kinda
drew this in gimp but the rest of it is icons
and text.
And at the top, I'm actually not quite sure
what this does in doom, so I put some random
icons up here.
I worked on adding enemies next.
I grabbed this little robot thing from Quaternius.
Comes fully animated already.
I just plopped him into the world, but he
doesn't do anything right now, but we can
fix that by adding some crude AI.
If we give him his own collision detection
like we have for ourselves, and then throw
together a quick finite state machine that
has him in idle, walk, and shooting behaviours.
We can really quickly and easily give him
a bit of personality.
See, now he sees me and walks towards me,
and even tries to impotently shoot at me.
Too bad only I have the gun.
So yeah of course, next thing is, I gave him
a gun, and I also coded up this force field
thing using some VVoronoi noise.
Now he's trying to take shots at me, and he
has a cool little force field around him.
And if I take a step back here and fire off
a few shots at him, his shield kinda changes
colour and eventually he dies and I added
this quick dissolve away effect.
Pretty happy how easy that was.
Lets make this look better now.
Lets make a quick level.
So what I'll do is quickly place down some
cubes and planes and stuff, kinda randomly.
We'll also place a few models that I grabbed
off of sketchfab that looked pretty cool.
That looks kinda neat, we've got floating
islands and different levels now, and I can
run around and jump and play, and do whatever
I want.
From the corners though, you can see that
this doesn't look as good as it could.
It's really apparent the shadows suck.
They don't extend out very far, and we don't
get that nice shadowing on the distance blocks.
Cascading shadow maps is typically the answer
to these kind of large landscapes, and as
luck would have it, there are options in three.js
that I was able to integrate.
Now if we peek out from the corner of the
map here, it looks great and we have shadows
going on.
If you look in the distance, you've got shadows,
but you've also got shadows nearby, and both
of them have enough detail.
I can also inject some of my own shader code
into three.js's for these cubes, add some
triplanar mapping and noise.
That saves me from actually modelling a level.
And that gets me this kinda neat futuristic
look.
I like it.
I also want to get some bloom in here, but
three.js doesn't quite do what I want.
So I copy pasted their's and I'm rewriting
it slightly to be driven by the alpha channel.
That way, I can selectively bloom those light
emitting squares and even my shots have a
kind of glow to them, but nothing else does.
I also played with the sky a bit.
What I did was combined a cubemap of a sky
with a cubemap of stars, then I drove the
mix between those using the sky's luminance,
and applied some colour grading.
There's also a bit of rotation using time,
and I added for that small bit of movement
to keep it from being totally static.
I also bloom out the sun manually via the
shader, so you get sort of a bleed over effect
in that direction.
This also means that those force fields on
the droids, they glow a bit now. which improves
the look quite a bit.
I also took the opportunity to add a little
radial blur effect.
It has a simple falloff from the center with
a bit of basic colour manipulation.
And here it is in action.
When activated, I contrast the center and
destaurate a bit towards the sides.
I dunno, see what works for you.
There's also a subtle vignette around the
edges of the screen because I like the look.
Anyway, thats about as far as I feel like
taking this.
It works.
I've got the beginnings of something here.
Maybe somebody wants to actually make this
into a real game.
So the code will be available on github, look
for an annoucement on twitter for when its
available.
Until next time, cheers.